hello everyone and welcome to a true
Masterpiece of a game from the VR Chess
Masters that is currently being played
in Dusseldorf Germany uh this is from
round one a Wesley Seoul versus Yang
shustov doodan and it's remarkable that
one of the players Falls for a false for
a trick okay maybe it's not a trick but
maybe it's just a known position uh
that's been played uh uh 50 years ago
but not just 50 years ago it's been
played 40 years ago 30 years ago it's
it's just been repeating itself and
someone always falls for it now we're
gonna get to that um uh this is not
rapid chest like we've covered in the
protest League this is classical chess
so players have a lot of time uh it's a
10 player round robin with 120 minutes
for the first 40 moves and then you get
additional 60 Minutes for for the next
20 moves and 15 minutes for the rest of
the game and you get a 30 second uh
increment starting from move 61. uh if
the uh in result for the tournament is a
tie between two players then we will
have a playoff it's gonna be two games
of I believe 10 minutes and then if that
ends in a draw there will be Armageddon
but that's we're far away from that this
is round one and we are here to enjoy
this uh beautiful game so let's see what
happened Wesley opens with Knight to F3
he goes for the ready opening D5 by dude
with G3 Knight to F6 Bishop to G2 and
now Pawn to C5 uh grabbing the full
Center as Wesley decided to control the
central with his pieces a very hyper
modern approach we have Castles by
Wesley and now Knight the C6 we have
Pawn to D4 E6 and now Pawn to C4 this is
all a very well known Theory the
captures on C4 Queen to A4 ready to
reclaim the pawn and now Bishop to D7 we
have Queen captures and C4 C capture
Sundee for Knight captures on D for now
with the triple attack on that C6 Knight
so Rook the C8 nicely developing and now
Knight to C3 you do have this uh
x-raying attack on the queen but there
just aren't any good discoveries so
Knight captures on D4 Queen captures and
now Bishop to C5 uh it seems like black
is getting very nice development
uh for pretty much the the price of
nothing so it's a very interesting to
see what Wesley has in store for Duda
here he plays Queen to H4 and okay the
the pawn on B7 is hanging you have to
defend that with Bishop to C6 and now
Rook to D1 attacking the black queen
here with Queen to B6 and this is where
the problem lies everyone plays Queen to
B6 in this position uh but it's just um
not possible to play this it seems like
you should be able to play this because
your Bishops are now beautifully placed
you're already attacking the F2 Pawn uh
The Rook is on a beautiful C8 Square
you're ready to Castle uh it seems like
everything is going your way but there's
a problem and Wesley shows it Bishop
captures on C6 with check uh before we
go into this line I would just like to
mention the Knight to the A4 although it
looks very nice for white attacks the
queen and the bishop and also the Knight
is nicely protected by the queen isn't
all that spectacular because after this
bishop captures an F2 check King F1 yes
now the queen is hanging and if you move
the queen to a weird Square you're going
to lose the bishop but it doesn't matter
Bishop captures and G2 check King
captures Queen to C6 check King captures
an F2 and yes white is up a piece but
only one more move because Knight the E4
with check the White Queen no longer
defends the Knight on A4 and after we
move the king queen cap for sun A4 uh
black uh regains material and is even up
a pawn in this uh crazy line so that's
why you don't do it and that's why
Bishop captures and C6 is the main move
here and okay Rook captures on C6 Queen
captures is a little bit better but
still it's a very tough position for
black to play Rook captures and C6 was
played and now we have Bishop to H6 and
this is uh in incredible as it is uh
this position has been repeating itself
uh throughout the last 50 years uh the
the first instance of it being played I
found a game between Sultan ribley and
Luba merlubovic from 1978 okay that's
like 45 years ago it's not 50. uh but
who knows how long uh ribly has been
sitting on this before actually getting
a chance to employ it against liub which
could easily be five years could be more
could be ten like uh you know Frank
Marshall uh was sitting seven years on
the Marshall attack before he actually
employed it against capablanca or okay
so they say uh but um yeah there's just
no good way to get out of this for black
because whatever you do seems
insufficient if you if you capture on H6
there's Queen captures on F6 The Rook is
hanging and okay you can Castle but then
come Knight the foreign is just really
really bad the the Knight Will gain
access to this F6 Square it's I mean
yeah a terrible terrible position for
black another thing you could do after
Bishop H6 is just Castle but this uh
doesn't work because of Bishop captures
and G7 and now after King captures you
will play Queen to G5 with check King to
each it now you're going to deliver
another chicken after King the g894 and
we get a very similar position where it
is just completely unplayable for uh for
black queen he's coming to H4 Knight is
coming to F6 uh it's game over so the
way do the defense this he plays Bishop
back to f8 okay now the G7 Pawn is
defended but now Wesley throws in the
real uh idea and that is a rook to D3
again this has all been played before so
truly incredible and it seems like you
could capture the B2 Pawn but the
problem is if you do this yes okay the
Knight is hanging uh look at this Rook
the B1 Rook the D1 also can be played
Rook to B1 even stronger and now okay
you can go like like the C2 then Rook
the C1 the the bishop controls that
square and if you go to A3 then you go
under the mask of The Rook Knight the D5
attacks the queen and once the queen
moves now you're gonna play Knight
captures and F6 G captures Queen
captures and black just falls apart The
Rook here is hanging once you move that
just Bishop captures King captures and
Rook captures on B7 there's no good way
to defend Checkmate you could play like
Rook to G7 but then just Rook the d8
check captors captures and this is
Checkmate so after Rook to D3 the B2
Pawn is off limits uh Knight to D5 is
what to do the tries and now comes the
Knight captures on d5e captures and the
bishop comes back Bishop to E3 attacking
the black queen and this is uh
completely unplayable for black Bishop
to C5 there is one game that uh where
Bishop to C5 was played but here Duda
tries Queen captures on B2 and it is now
as of move 18 that we have a completely
new game but if Wesley finds the correct
idea
uh the the game is uh completely winning
for him there is only one move that wins
the game here for Wesley so feel free to
pause pause the video here and try to
find this uh silent maneuver while I
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on uh connecting the
entire board and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Bishop
to D4 this move solves all of your
problems and imposes uh um
insurmountable uh problems for for black
uh because now the queen is attacked the
rook and A1 is defended the bishop on f8
cannot be developed uh there's just uh
not nothing for black here Queen to B4
was played okay now the bishop cannot
move or rather you could but you don't
want to trade Queens here uh Rook the B3
attacks the black queen queen back to E7
offering a queen trade and Wesley could
keep the Queens on the board with some
like Queen F4 or queen to H5 but he
shows that this is completely winning
even with the queen trade Queen captures
on E7 now you could capture with the
bishop you could capture with the King
doesn't really make a difference with uh
do the captures with the King to keep
defending his G7 Pawn but now Rook
captures on B7 with check King the E6
now Rook the B8 completely paralyzing
the back rank now the bishop cannot move
as the rook and h8 would will hang so
Pawn to H5 dude has to find some sort of
counter play he's dreaming of getting
this Pawn to H3 to at least have some uh
counter play but of course Wesley will
not allow this Rook 8 to B1 we have Pawn
to H4 and now just King to G2 we have
King to F5 now comes King to F3 we have
characters captures and Rook to C4 so he
does find some counter play but just
Pawn to E3 by Wesley so what can what
what can do that right here the bishop
cannot move the Rook cannot move because
the bishop will hang uh this is just a
very very sad to look at Rook to see
Rook to C2 was tried it's a it's a very
good attempt if if Wesley makes one slow
move like let's say Bishop captures on
A7 okay we can even throw it then Rook
to H2 and suddenly black is back in the
game because you're threatening
Checkmate and you don't really care
about the bishop on f8 uh hanging you
would have to spend the move to defend
then Bishop to D6 Black's position
suddenly comes alive so instead after
Rook to C2 Rook won the B5 saying that
okay now if you bring the Rook to H2
just recapture Sun D5 check we can even
show it if you want uh and after this
check you don't really care next move
you capture the bishop and you have a
square for your king so you're gonna be
up a piece so after Rook one to B5 King
to G6 by do that now comes a rook
captures on D5 Rook capture sunny2 the
material is still equal but Black's
position is completely paralyzed we have
Rook D to d8 now the bishop is lost and
Rook the H2 and now do that will have to
trade the the bishop for the F2 Pawn we
have Rook captures on f8 Rook a captures
um and I have to wait to check King to
E4 and now Pawn to F6 so we'll do that
we'll still try to survive this uh but
of course you see that's impossible Rook
the B7 goes after the pawn uh Pawn to A6
and now uh even Rook to A8 and now you
can go after the pawn you can go after
the G7 Pawn that's uh I mean uh
completely a complete paralysis Rook day
two Rook 8 to A7 now putting pressure on
the G7 Pawn Rook the H7 and now King to
F3 uh Rook to A5 do the try something
but none nothing can move here just Rook
the B6 puts pressure on the A6 spawn and
also prepares uh to push the E5 Pawn as
the F6 Pawn is now pinned so Rook the G5
uh hoping to get that Rook to H3 in to
get some counter play but Wesley does
not even allow that King the G2 stops
Rook to H3 with Pawn to A5 okay the pawn
is now defended but it just Pawn to E4
uh we have rooked the G4 now the the
bishop will I'll be lost if you push E5
so just King to F3 kicks away the rock
rock the G5 and even Bishop to E3
improving the position of the bishop
before advancing the E5 Rook the E5 with
Bishop there for Rook to C5 and finally
Pawn to E5 you cannot capture because
the F Pawn is spinned uh Rook the h8 was
played not just Rook B to A6 puts more
pressure on the A5 Pawn we have rooked
the d8 and now e captures an F6 finally
going for the capture G captures and
Rook captures on A5 uh zero counter play
here for for do that he's down a full
piece Rook the C3 check was played with
King to G4 and it was in this position
animal 48 that Yang shift of Duda
resigned to the game as there is nothing
more to be done here you have zero
control play uh Wesley is just up a full
bishop and this will be well this would
be self-torture if the if
uh if you continue this I don't know if
there's a nicer word for self-torture
pretty sure there is but I don't know it
yeah and also uh interesting
um I've tried to figure out what VR
chess master stands for I I couldn't
um uh find even on their on their uh
homepage it just says we are Chess
Masters it does not say what the VR
stands for so if any of you know what a
WR chess master stands for uh do share
in the comments as I would also very
much like to know so yeah incredible as
it is people just keep falling for this
and it's uh it's a fun line to play
especially if you like the reti so you
might want to remember this position if
black plays Queen to B6 is just game
over you you will go for captures
captures and Bishop to H6 uh yeah
Everyone Falls for this uh throughout
history we've seen it happen like
a 45 year old trick if you count in uh
how long uh ribbly has been sitting on
this could even be a 50 year old uh old
trick because it's not like he prepared
it and then he immediately employed it
against Dubois which probably he knew
about it for a while but yeah that's the
game know your Classics and the good
things that will happen I would like to
thank CDs for trade Ricky black castor
Johnson Robert Trenton and Rodney Barr
for her contribution to my channel thank
you I have to really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day